foreign
Chris is with us in Dallas Texas to
start this hour hi Chris welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey Dave thank you so much for having me
sure what's up
so I'm a high school senior right now
taking just kind of a personal finance
class and I was just wondering if you're
concerned about how you know the
national debt reaching 30 trillion
dollars and how that should affect just
our overall personal finance strategy
um
well I'm sorry as a high school senior
you're having to worry about such things
um
uh
I've got a long history of fretting and
alternately being angry about the uh
national debt being out of control
mainly because it represents a congress
that's out of control and we don't seem
to have the backbone in the American
people to vote the bozos out
so they keep spending
like there's no tomorrow
and um everybody's a little bit lazy
about it so it just keeps going and
going and going so yeah I'm with you it
it's bothersome it's um obviously
there's a Tipping Point somewhere
um I will tell you that the uh end of
the world has been predicted as long as
I can remember due to the national debt
or due to whatever other Boogeyman you
want to come up with
and um I actually read a book uh when I
was a little bit older than you called
bankruptcy 1984 that predicted that the
national debt was going to hockey stick
and the nation would collapse in 1984.
obviously that was wrong
[Laughter]
there was another book that a friend of
mine wrote called the coming economic
earthquake predicting the exact same
thing in the same decade
he was wrong
I had another friend of mine wrote a
book about the end of the world due to
why 2K do you know what that is Chris
yes yeah year 2000 yeah exactly when the
computer's all turned over the world was
going to come down and the uh the uh uh
we were a little bit worried that the
entire electric electronic grid would
collapse and a lot of people bought
water and bullets and uh all kinds of
things to get ready for the end times
and the uh New Year's Eve came and went
nothing happened except three days later
the stock market went through the roof
up
and so um I just I I have honestly I'm
not making fun completely but I look
back on all the things I've worried
about and none of them have happened so
um I think it's bad because I think it
represents a lack of discipline on the
American people's part and on our
quote-unquote Representatives part I
think it's pitiful
it's outrageous but does it affect my
investing not a dime
not a dime I don't sit and worry about
it I invest based on good long-term
track records because the debt's been
out of control as long as I've been
alive
and uh so I've been investing in
investing and investing if it ever
absolutely fell in on itself there's not
anything you could have invested in
except bullets that would protect you
so I wouldn't I wouldn't fret about it
um and the next time someone could you
know comes to me and one of the other
things I'll just as a side note for our
listeners out there and for Jay Jay may
not know this about me um it is one of
the things I have vowed that when I get
old I am not going to be one of those
financial guys that writes an end times
book
because most people in my world you know
we go along we teach people to get
wealthy we teach them about all this and
then we get enough knowledge that this
stuff starts concerning us and so we
write the end of the world book and it's
coming soon usually when we get old and
I've just vowed I'm not even if I'm
tempted I'm not going to write as a
matter of fact I've even told my
publishing team to refuse to publish it
if I did write it so if you have a
moment
getting the mistake of doing it to
myself burn burn the manuscript throw it
in the fire just it it apparently
um
takes more than a single president being
a because we've had multiple of
that um
it takes more than
I think it takes to collapse This Thing
Called America
yeah you know I I remember thinking that
when X or Y president got elected way
back there like before some of you were
born that that was it
that's a sign it's over yeah Jesus is
coming you know and he didn't and we
didn't die and the nation survived the
idiocy in the white house that's true
and the lack of Morality In the White
House and the whatever in the White
House said and you know we'll survive um
whatever we're going through right now
it's just we're more resilient than I
than I think we think we are in the
middle of the night when we wake up
scared that's a really good point Dave I
do think that we're resilient as people
and also as a nation and a lot of this
stuff is so cyclical you know the sky is
falling and then somebody comes and does
you know one or two things that are just
you know whatever and everybody does a
big deep breath and then somebody else
comes and they spend more and it's like
uh you know I think all this stuff just
goes in a big wheel and uh you know for
your own piece sometimes you just gotta
let it let it remain external and not
get let it get into you so much yeah and
when you look back on it you go you know
it I it was it was a lot bigger deal in
my head yeah I mean you talked to
somebody who lived during the Great
Depression
yeah that that was real yeah I find in
moments like this when you just look
back and go okay it gives you a little
bit of perspective to go okay this is
this is not any crazier than any other
moment in history you know what I mean
yeah and and
yeah I think the um you know what is
different
is access to
conspiracy theories facts it's the
social media internet I mean because it
used to be you had to really work to
find Kooks that's right and now they are
delivered to you because you've been
looking at other Kooks and so the
algorithm sends you a holistic oh it'll
just put it up you don't got stuck in
the kooky algorithm and you're gonna get
lit up with Kooks and so you know if you
think the world's coming to an end and
you type that in about three times
you're gonna have a lot of incoming End
Time stuff showing up on your desktop
and all of a sudden you're gonna start
to believe the dead gum world's coming
to an end and it's the same thing as you
know again when I started all of this a
million years ago we didn't have the
inputs you know the moral of the story
is there is a moral to the story we're
going to finally get there watch your
inputs
so good Dave you know you become what
you consume and who you hang around with
so are you watching the news 24 7. right
you're gonna be pissed off all the time
because it used to just be that it was
Fox News MSNBC and you go you know I
used to be Walter Cronkite and you had
to wait till six o'clock there's that
that was it and then you got 24 7. 24 7.
and then you got 24 7 both sides of the
political Spectrum yep uh yelling at
each other yep and now you got YouTube
Instagram and all and it's not even it's
not even real news outlets anymore it's
just it's just
the stuff that we call news now we used
to call tabloid oh true that well I can
go on there and make news and somebody
listen to me well there you go
I might have to only I'll tell you the
truth I won't be out here telling you
fake news I'll tell you the truth
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]